staying ahead investing in Europe for
Europe's economy to stay ahead in the
global competitiveness race we need to
boost investment investment remains
fifteen percent lower than it used to be
although Europe's economy has already
begun to recover from the crisis
economic growth remains slow and
investors remain quarters to shift
economic growth into a higher gear and
create more jobs we need to invest more
in the real economy that means investing
in areas that will enhance our
competitiveness like education research
innovation energy infrastructure and the
environment we also need to support
small and medium-sized businesses which
are the backbone of the European economy
the European Union is helping countries
and businesses to work as a team
identifying priorities and engineering
solutions the core part of this strategy
is that you use investment plan for
Europe which should mobilize 315 billion
euros of investment over the next three
years this ambitious plan will construct
a better environment for investors it
will strip away regulatory barriers and
channel investment that drive the
economy forward in strategic sectors and
projects with great potential the
European fund for strategic investments
will help projects to hit the road by
providing guarantees to encourage
private investors as part of the plan
there will be a hub offering technical
and financial advice and a portal
matching investors with project
promoters smaller medium-sized
businesses will also benefit from easier
access to the available finance
faster growth and investment to create
jobs is Europe's top priority I'm
working together as a team Europe can
make the investments it needs to stay
ahead
European economy stronger together